you are gonna be a drag queen today like
I feel that yes own it and don't
apologize or say that it's any less
because when you look in the mirror
you're gonna be like oh she's real okay
well I'll be a drag queen goddamn it so
I'm a huge fan of RuPaul's Drag Race
my experience with drag is virtually
zero the reason that I want to do this
challenge is because I'm curious what
it's like to actually get in their skin
to be dressed up like goin these Queens
one in particular stood out her name is
Miss cracker and she is known for an
online YouTube series she has in which
she wears drag doing everyday things and
I thought it would be really cool to
have her come in and be my drag mother
to show me the ropes and transform me
into a temporary drag queen she's
finally here I am joined by my cracker
hello drag superstar and contestant on
season 10 of RuPaul's Drag Race yes
absolutely she's excited
I started drag when it was possible to
do drag without knowing about RuPaul's
Drag Race
since then drag has become a
international mainstream medium it's on
the global stage part of what inspired
me to want to do this was you have this
online series where you do everyday
things and drag so what does that like
for you being a drag in public helps you
learn to separate how you look from who
you are a tip that I give to people when
they're starting out on anything is
empty your glass if you have this little
glass that's half full of knowledge
about drag I can't fill it up all the
way with all the knowledge that I have I
don't want this to be me and
authentically co-opting what it is to be
a drag queen because I'm not performing
I'm not lip-synching I'm not dancing I'm
not doing any of that I'm just getting
the aesthetic beauty part of it I don't
want you to downplay the fact that
you're trying drag as something
illegitimate because you don't do it all
the time don't think that this is not
real drag every time you're a drag is
real drag so you are gonna be a drag
queen today I'm gonna use 99%
alcohol to remove some of the oils from
your face now you're gonna sweat
throughout the day so it's gonna come
off nice and easy I feel like my face
just got like yeah suction back yup my
daughter's not leaving that bar without
her wig we're gonna take the glue stick
we're gonna start at the inside and
we're coating the backside of your
eyebrow hairs don't grease your whole
face with the foundation stick just like
under your eyes here on your cheekbones
and then spread it out from there now we
have a nice contour cream it's very
telling that what we used on your face
for this highlight is called clown white
a little pyramid of contour and a
contour oh my god that could be my drag
name you'll know when you look in the
mirror you'll be like I know she is now
we're gonna contour your nose we're
gonna bring it down to a nice little
point there are many setting powders
that you can use this one is the
cheapest and the best just like me
Gollum yeah look out Sasha galore
okay ahh so there we've deleted your
face and now it's just shapes I'm going
to highlight under your eyebrow we're
gonna give your eyelid a little bit of
dimension by highlighting right in the
middle I'm gonna put a wing on your eye
okay do you need like a card or
something for it
I don't need training wheels girl ah
okay I will murder you if you open your
eye you open your eyes look down again I
will break your legs off and beat you
with them I want to dig around in your
tear ducts with like super sticky paint
and then I'm gonna powder over it with
powder that's just gonna definitely roll
under your eyeballs and back into your
skull I just know I have no idea what I
look like
next up let's Kara it feels like almost
like it's stuck on the middle of my I
would yeah it definitely is stuck in the
middle of your eyelid your lip is moved
by these little muscles and there's a
little groove where the muscles connect
to it you're gonna draw right in that
groove can you open your eyes
look at that she looks gorgeous I think
this is the prettiest queen I've ever
painted like ha ha ha so like the front
part is over here I think we're gonna
flip it back yep
yeah she's face down right now I'm
working her out from behind
okay we're essentially done now I'm just
[ __ ] around we're done yeah okay this
is weird because I have no idea what I
look like right now so I'm still
picturing myself as like Matt the boy
oh my god oh my god oh my god what just
woman watch it what's her name well
somebody said earlier the first one that
was in the contour and a contour
mm-hm and a contour right here
[Music]
so now I'm going to go around the office
and get some reactions from people do
you have any idea who might rise oh hi
did you recognize me oh not at all
really I only heard your voice did I do
this thing with your like me laughs he
goes oh my god I do do that I'm hitting
the streets and going on the subway and
full drag to see my friends at the bar
they don't know I'm coming and they
definitely won't be expecting my new
look I'm noticing that people are either
flat-out ignored me or like gawking at
me I cannot believe what they are seeing
what smells kind of Lexi's nobody knows
who I am
[Music]
my padding's falling out I can't [ __ ]
walk in heels I mean miss cracker
bull lesson it's like 40 degrees out of
here but I'm really not even that cold
I think there's oh thank you I'm about
to be at the bar and I can't wait to see
my friends reactions
[Applause]
[Music]
my friends are shook and even though
they still know it's me it's like
they're interacting with a completely
different person I had up town to see
Miss cracker at her gig and show some
support for my rock star drag mother and
to let her know how the nights going the
exhaustion is hitting my dogs are
barking from these heels and my time in
drag is quickly coming to a close now
you're gonna sweat throughout the day so
it's gonna come off nice and easy try
some baby wipes oh great
alright I need to my eye makeup remover
for this it was incredible being
transformed into a drag queen by you
thank you so much
Oh No thank you for me yesterday was
just very exciting and I was just
looking forward to your face when you
saw in the mirror I loved it I cannot
[ __ ] walk in heels that's something
that really can't be taught it's just
something that you figure out as you
wear heels more and more a message that
I would leave to you and to anybody that
wants to have a relationship with drag
is make sure that it is absolutely your
own relationship to drag without anybody
else interfering